we begin in india where calls are
growing for a national lockdown as
covid19 deaths remain
on the rise nearly 3 800 people lost
their lives in a single day
hospitals are struggling to treat
patients as they run out of beds
and oxygen for weeks now volunteer
groups have been delivering crucial
supplies
and dw reporters namisha jaiswal and
sharikh ahmad
have been to meet individuals who are
putting their lives on the line to save
others
dinesh sinha has spent the last two days
right here
on the road in front of a sikh temple 50
kilometers from home
his son has the corona virus and has
also developed a severe lung infection
he urgently needs to be hospitalized but
his father
says even this makeshift arrangement is
a blessing
these people are working 24 hours
providing oxygen cylinders
otherwise it's very difficult to get
oxygen or to get a bed in a hospital
this morning i visited 15 or 20
hospitals to look for a bed for him
there isn't a single bed all of them
refused us
for the last two weeks delhi has been
facing a severe shortage of medical
oxygen
this is a life-saving last resort a free
oxygen service run by khalsa help
a sikh group volunteers here consider
the risks they are taking to be
secondary to the central tenet of
service
in sikhism several of them have already
been infected
but those here tell us they aren't
afraid
they say they must do something to save
these lives
i go home to sleep for two hours
my wife
[Music]
every few minutes critical patients are
brought in
the group has nine trucks scouring
nearby plants for cylinders
the oxygen here is provided for free as
patients continue to be rushed in here
many hospitals in delhi have stopped
taking in new patients
because of the oxygen crisis they're
putting out sos messages on twitter
begging for help as they only have hours
sometimes
minutes of oxygen left this hospital
is one of them the previous night was a
close shave
after waiting for hours at oxygen plants
tagging authorities on twitter
and even reducing oxygen flows to
subsistence levels to make it last
longer
the hospital got supplies in the nick of
time
doctors here tell us that supplies that
used to last them two weeks
now evaporate in 36 hours
they cannot predict if the next round
will reach them on time
turning away patients for logistical
reasons is
heartbreaking for doctors when we refuse
many of these patients are helplessly
pleading
in this profession because is because
they wanted to help other
people through their sickness and
illness
if they are not able to do that that by
itself
is uh taking an emotional moral ethical
toll on them
a rare few do get lucky
back at the oxygen service sinha has
finally managed to arrange a bed for his
son
immediately his cylinder is rolled
towards another patient
two weeks into the oxygen crisis here
every labored breath is a gift
and joining us now to talk more about
volunteer efforts
and helping the sick is inayat singh
kakar she is a health activist with the
people's health movement and she is
joining us from
india thank you so much for being on the
program today
how are you managing to get relief to
the sick when there's so little oxygen
to go around
i mean it's extremely extremely
challenging i mean you know one aspect
is that there is very little oxygen to
go around because
uh you know the daily uh requirement the
daily allocation of delhi
is not even being met and the second
issue is with regards to information
gaps
uh now even you know even in places
where there is oxygen available
it runs out very fast people don't get
to know where it's available where do
you go how do you
cure it uh people you know i mean often
there is
oxygen available in refilling plants but
people don't have empty cylinders
um and so coordinating all of this is
very very difficult
uh but we do have linkages with you know
other volunteer groups with people like
you showed in your story who are
providing oxygen
um and we do our best um you know to get
them oxygen another big challenge is
that
um you know that uh that the prices for
oxygen have really skyrocketed and when
you're dealing with the supplier you
don't really know whether they're
legitimate or whether it's being sold on
the black market
um and that is you know that is a that's
a big
uh problem because also i mean a lot of
people can't afford these extremely high
uh prices so we often also have to
resort to fundraising for individual
patients if uh
you know if that is required we have
been hearing that more foreign aid
is arriving uh foreign help to the
country is that something that you're
noticing
on the ground um and if you're not
noticing it yet i mean how hopeful are
you
for the future prospects in the next
weeks and the next days
um i think a lot of organizations
particularly that are
you know providing oxygen there are
organizations seek organizations
that have set up what are called oxygen
lungers which is basically i mean it's a
place where anyone can come to get free
oxygen
and i think a lot of these organizations
are receiving foreign aid
they you know organizations are flying
in oxygen concentrators
for individuals providing these in their
homes we got to know
uh yesterday that um you know
ventilators
that arrived from abroad have been
distributed to central government
hospitals
so we're hopeful that things will see an
improvement but i'm not sure
if uh you know if our system has worked
fast
enough to address the growing crisis i
feel like we're still very much
you know taking knee-jerk reactions and
we're still trying to fill the shortages
and not really you know we're not really
able to
um to to respond to the crisis
that we're seeing and that we will be
seeing in the coming few days
and as you take that really proactive
approach i mean to fill these gaps in
capacities uh that the system does have
in india
tell us i mean how are you coping on a
day-to-day basis your your organization
yourself uh are you receiving for
example
you know some sort of psychological
support in in dealing with what you're
dealing with every day i mean this is
life and death
uh i mean i think it's extremely
distressing you know a lot of us are not
getting enough sleep
um we're usually working around the
clock there have been days where um you
know some of us have been sleeping once
in 48 hours
um there is a sense of uh you know
despair
uh when you're not able to help patients
uh earlier
you know we were having to help patients
get oxygen at home but now we also get
sos calls from patients who are admitted
in hospitals
um and that's very complicated because
when somebody reaches out to you
for an icu bed you also have to ensure
that the hospital has adequate oxygen
and
you know we're not we don't have access
to system resources to be able to do all
of that
um and i think i don't think a lot of us
are really processing the emotional toll
that this is taking you know a lot of
young volunteers are dealing with cases
where patients are not surviving i think
there is this um you know general
feeling of guilt
for not being able to do everything to
really save the patient and and
i think we're all very very aware of
uh the limitations that we're facing um
we
you know our phone numbers are public we
get constant calls for help we are able
to respond to some people we're not able
to respond to some people
um but but yes we're trying to set up a
more organized form of you know
providing support and psychosocial
support to each other
um and in fact yesterday i spoke to a
therapist you know um
i mean asking her if she can do some
group sessions online for volunteers
um so that we can deal with this
collective trauma that we're all facing
and i also
worry and i also fear for the you know
for the for what's going to happen once
all of this
you know also goes down well you're
doing incredible work uh under difficult
circumstances
and um and and we know that uh you know
your time is also very precious so so
we thank you so much for taking the time
to speak with us here on dw news to tell
us
a little bit about what you're
experiencing there in a volunteer
capacity
in the country as as the death toll
mounts as we mentioned
inia singh kakar health activist
with the people's health movement we
appreciate it thank you
and germany is about to send its second
shipment of emergency aid to
india the air force has already sent a
plane with 120 ventilators and medicine
also on board a team of medical experts
several european states and other
countries including the u.s and taiwan
have also joined
in the aid effort
and benjamin alvarez gruber is standing
by in wunstdorf
air base in lower saxony germany from
where this shipment just took
off uh benjamin what's been happening
near you
that's right sarah we are standing right
next to the runway here at the air force
base of the german
army of the air force just a few minutes
ago the a400m military cargo plane took
off to
abu dhabi to then continue the trip to
delhi as you just said on saturday
another plane landed
already sending a crew that will help to
operate
this oxygen generator machine that is on
board
of this plane there will be a german
team helping their indian colleagues to
use
this machine that compresses air to use
it
for oxygen for several hospitals that
are in dire need
to get in germany joined some 40
countries
offering aid to india um tell us a
little bit more about the efforts and
how far
they might be able to go
that's right germany is joining more
than 40 countries
over the past days there have been a lot
of cargo planes
arriving from australia from the us from
the uk
what is special about this shipment that
germany is standing so we have this
takeoff today we'll have a
takeoff tomorrow as well with the same
plane
a400m airbus cargo transporter
what's interesting is that the german
team will stay there
the first team arrived on saturday they
assessed the situation there
and we talked to several officials
before
this live and they told us that the
security aspect is also very important
if we consider that there is indeed a
black market of oxygen
in the country and also over concerns
that the aid that several countries
are sending out is not reaching the
hospitals and is still in costumes for
example
in airports or in several halls that
have been
put in place by the government so
there's also a fear when we look there's
india media reporting that the aid is
not reaching also other
regions in india so they will be really
careful that this
machine and all the help that is being
sent to india right now can be used as
soon as it arrives there
dw reporter benjamin alvarez kuba thank
you